♪
>> Lawrence: THANK YOU FOR
JOINING ME.
I'M LAWRENCE JONES.
AND TONIGHT BLUE STATES PROBLEMS
ARE COMING TO TEXAS.
YOU MAY HAVE HEARD THAT MY HOME
STATE OF TEXAS JUST PICKED UP
TWO CONGRESSIONAL SEATS ONE FROM
CALIFORNIA AND ONE FROM TEXAS.
IT'S NOT HARD TO UNDERSTAND WHY
TEXAS IS A GREAT PLACE TO RAISE
A FAMILY.
IT'S CLEANER, PLUS THE SCHOOL IS
MORE PREVALENT AND THE COST OF
LIVING IS MUCH MORE AFFORDABLE.
AMERICANS WANT TO BE FREE.
THEY DON'T LIKE BEING RESTRICTED
BY GOVERNMENT THAT LOCKED
THREATT THEM DOWN, MASKED THEM
UP AND TAXED THEM INTO OBLIVION.
PEOPLE FLEEING TO TEXAS FROM
CITIES LIKE LOS ANGELES OR NEW
YORK MIGHT BE SURPRISED TO FIND
FAMILIAR PROBLEMS WAITING FOR
THEM IN THE LONE STAR STATE.
I MEAN, AUSTIN.
THE CAPITAL CITY OF AUSTIN IS
FACING A CRIME PROBLEM, A DRUG
PROBLEM, AND A HOMELESS PROBLEM.
BASICALLY ALL THE QUALITY OF
LIFE ISSUES BLUE STATE
TRANSPLANTS THOUGHT THEY WERE
LEAVING BEHIND.
RESIDENTS SAY THEY HAVE NEVER
SEEN ANYTHING LIKE THIS.
BUT THE CITY LEADERSHIP RUN BY
DEMOCRATS, WELL, EXCEPT FOR THE
LONE REPUBLICAN THERE, THEY ARE
COMPLETELY DENYING IT.
SO I WENT TO AUSTIN MYSELF TO
SEE IT.
WATCH.
>> YOU ARE DOWN HERE, YOU ARE
READY TO PARTY.
>> IT'S A BUSY CITY.
>> WE COME OUT TO HAVE SOME FUN.
>> IT'S A GREAT TIME.
EVERYBODY IS SAFE.
>> IT'S AMERICA.
IT'S MY HOME.
>> Lawrence: THIS USED TO BE ONE
OF THE CROWN JEWELS OF AUSTIN.
BUT, AS CAN YOU SEE, ANOTHER
TENT CITY.
>> NEVER BEEN LIKE THIS BEFORE.
>> I'M A DEMOCRAT BUT I HAVE
LEARNED MY LESSON.
>> I'M JUST FREAKED OUT.
>> SOMETHING NEEDS TO BE DONE.
>> Lawrence: TWO YEARS AGO, THE
CITY COUNCIL VOTED TO GET RID OF
A CITY ORDINANCE THAT BANNED
CAMPING ON PUBLIC LAND AND
PARKS.
THE RESULT 11% INCREASE IN THE
HOMELESS POPULATION.
>> YOU HAVE PEOPLE THAT ARE
ASSAULTED, PEOPLE WHO ARE
ROBBED.
WE HAVE HAD HOME INVASIONS.
>> ONE NIGHT I WAS AT MY
NEIGHBOR'S HOUSE AND WE SAW THEM
CLEANING THEIR GUNS.
>> YOU FOUND NEEDLES?
>> YES.
ON THE FLOOR.
I DIDN'T KNOW WHAT IT WAS.
I PICKED IT UP.
>> AUSTIN IS STARTING TO LOOK
LIKE SKID ROW.
>> THAT IS THE LAST THING I WANT
TO HAVE HAPPEN.
>> THE GUY IS WALKING AROUND
WITH A MACHETE THREATENING
PEOPLE.
>> IT STARTED WITH BOX CUTTERS
AS A WEAPON.
NOW WE -- SADLY WE JOKE THAT WE
ARE THE MACHETE CAPITAL OF
TEXAS.
>> THIS MAY THE CITY RESIDENTS
GOT THEIR VOICE BACK WHEN THEY
VOTED IN A LANDSLIDE VICTORY TO
REINSTATE PROP B WHAT IS THE
CITY LEADERSHIP DOING HERE IN
AUSTIN?
>> THE CITY OF AUSTIN LETS THEM
DO WHATEVER THEY WANT.
PLEASE DO YOUR JOBS.
LEAVE YOUR NEEDLES SO GETS
LITTLE KIDS CAN GET.
>> WE AS A PEOPLE AND CITIZENS
ARE LED TO FEND FOR OURSELVES.
>> Lawrence: DO YOU WANT THAT TO
BE THE IMAGE OF AUSTIN?
>> ONE OF THE REASONS I DON'T
LIKE THAT IMAGE BECAUSE I DON'T
THINK IT'S TRUE.
>> A GUY IS WALKING AROUND RIGHT
OUTSIDE OF CITY HALL WITH A
MACHETE.
THREATENING PEOPLE.
THAT'S ILLEGAL.
THAT'S BREAKING THE LAW.
>> AND WE'RE DEALING WITH THAT
WITH A TOUGH CHALLENGE.
>> THEY VOTED TO DEFUND THE
POLICE LAST YEAR AND REALLOCATE
MONEY, AND, AS SUCH, OFFICERS
ARE LEAVING AT VERY HIGH RATES.
I THINK THE CAUSE OF OUR ILLNESS
THAT IS TAKING OVER OUR CITY IS
FAILED LEADERSHIP.
>> I HAVE GOT TO SAY I TALKED
WITH THE COPS.
THEY TELL ME THAT THEY WANT TO
BE ABLE TO ENFORCE THE LAWS BUT
THEY HAVE BEEN TOLD TO STAND
BACK.
>> MY POLICE CHIEF TELLS ME
THAT'S NOT TRUE.
>> I KNOW ONE THING, CONSTANT.
WE ARE GOING TO VOTE THEM OUT.
WE COULD EITHER ESCAPE OR RUN
FROM THIS PROBLEM OR FACE IT
STRAIGHT ON AND WE CAN MAKE A
POSITIVE CHANGE.
>> DO YOU HAVE A COMMITMENT TO
GO AND ENGAGE THESE MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC TO COME UP WITH SOME
SORT OF SOLUTION?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
IT'S MY PRACTICE AND I HAVE BEEN
DOING THAT.
♪
>> Lawrence: DON'T WORRY, GUYS.